hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to another
hazel devlog so last time we talked
about shadows and you guys were
totally into that so i thought that i
would make a bit of a follow-up video
and in fact it's probably going to be
a bunch of follow-up videos because
there's just so much so much stuff to
talk about when it comes to shadows and
the way i implemented them and just
lighting in general in a game engine i
mean it's one of the most fundamental
things in computer graphics
ever this is all obviously work in
progress everything that i show here
during the devlogs is very much subject
to change however i also have a bit of a
habit of not wanting to show
too much before it's like before i'm
happy with it which is something that
i'm trying to avoid because this should
be like a journal and
you know i shouldn't just be showing you
know great looking stuff when it's done
so the point is
i'm gonna try and do a devlog probably
at least once a week
just to show you exactly the state of
things as long as i'm working on i'm not
always working on hazel dev like week to
week to week
because there's a lot of other projects
and you know the game engine series and
c plus plus stuff and
various other like code review videos
that i might be doing but when i am
working on hazel dev i'm just gonna make
a bit of a pledge here to just
try and show you guys a lot more i also
had this idea of looking through the
comments of the last devlog video
in every devlog video that i make so in
other words we're just gonna open up
the comments from the last episode and
i'm gonna try and answer some of your
questions
okay so of course the cat alika was the
primary focus of the last um
episode i had no idea that a kitten
would be so distracted i'm kidding of
course i did
at least means great name for a cat
leafguard everyone everyone loves that
anyway we'll skip past the russian
comments because i know not everyone
here speaks russian but i'll just say
that everyone is really happy with the
name of lifeka which is really cool my
wife actually
picked that name it wasn't me it was
technically this kitten was like a gift
to her and she
she picked the name alevka i really like
it as well so that's that's the story of
that so i can't really take credit for
that that's all her now i have to do
interest with the kitty every time i
already failed that
let's try and find some like shadow
maybe related related comments hey
trainer someone interested in getting to
audio programming wondering to what
extent hazel will have an audio engine
so
hazel the plan for hazel is i actually
already have a repository called hazel
audio i
i played a little bit with audio earlier
on in the year
the plan is definitely to have pretty
extensive audio and hazel i myself love
audio i'm a musician as well so i
definitely want to have
hazel be quite capable of audio don't
don't think that i'm forgetting about
audio completely
but obviously you know when it comes to
a game engine audio is like one of those
things that you develop towards the end
probably you make sure the rendering is
set up the scripting everything so you
can actually make a game
and then audio kind of comes at the end
so it is coming it's just that my
priorities are kind of
a little bit in different places god now
i know why you were gone for this long
you must have been working on this
see that's kind of what i mean i should
have probably made more videos of my
progress instead of just disappearing
for two weeks but sometimes the software
engineer side of me wants to just
you know back when i worked at ea and i
didn't really you know make as many
videos as i do
now that i'm like a full-time youtuber i
don't know
hazel developer back then it was kind of
nice to just you know come to work sit
down at your desk and not have to
worry about like oh i should record a
video for this or i should show this off
you know
just coming to work putting some music
in and programming
is just a little bit of a feeling that
i've been missing lately so i kind of
forgot about youtube and then just
i was like okay that's it i'm a software
engineer working on shadows let's get
this stuff done and it was really fun
but in retrospect i do kind of miss
sharing that journey with you guys as
well as just having like a bit of a
journal
of of the progress that i'm making when
i'm working on such a feature so
no guarantees for the future but as i
said i am definitely going to try and
share more with you guys hi channel do
you think it would be possible to post
your live streams for those who can't
join youtube differences so yeah live
streams get posted for all patreons five
dollars a month you get access to the
whole backlog
of all the live streams that i've ever
done on twitch just as unlisted youtube
links that you can check out whenever
you like i really enjoy these more
rambling videos
well thank you i like the devlog format
very much yeah i'm really happy that you
guys
really liked the devlog and let me know
what you think of me reading the
comments and stuff i think it's just
maybe a little bit more interactive when
you guys can leave a comment and you can
actually see me reply to it and like
talk about it instead of just not never
knowing if i see it or not
are you on usa no i'm from melbourne in
australia
where can i get the hazel game engine
demo thing patreon.com the channel hello
set up playing
never speed no limits game from 2018 see
your name in the credits okay i'm really
good graphics for android and get yeah i
think need for speed no limits has
really good graphics especially back in
2015 when we launched it
it had i think some of the best mobile
graphics of
any game out there so i definitely have
to say that i'm proud of
proud of the whole team for that so
today that the main thing that i wanted
to talk about was
some of the improvements that i've made
to the shadows in the last few days over
the weekend really
usually i try not to work on weekends
but these shadows were just keeping me
up at night i just wanted to wrap it up
and actually
have them be more or less finished and i
think they're at that stage now
the main concerns that i had and i think
i remember seeing a comment that i i
didn't find today but
um where in regards to how the how the
shadows actually work
for a large scene because whilst i did
talk about the fact that i have made
them work for a large scene
i really didn't show that off in the
devlog i mean ultimately i just i
just did show them kind of centered on a
little model in the in the middle of the
world and
that maybe wasn't a good demonstration
of it
so right now i do want to show them in
just a little bit more of it
because a serious kind of world context
there were a few bugs with the shadows
in the last dialogue that i have ironed
out as well so as far as i can tell
right now
they are fairly stable as far as shadows
or shadow mapping goes
there are obviously areas in which you
might have to like increase the bias or
change
change like the near and far plane of
the view frostums for the shadow map and
various other settings because that's
what shadow maps are like there's just a
lot of tweaking that usually needs to be
done to get them to look
right i think i'm going to make a video
in the future talking a little bit about
how i implemented some of the nicer
features such as the fading between
cascades and
where i even took the inspiration from
that and practically how it was achieved
let me know if you guys are interested
in that i think i'll make that later on
in the week potentially but ultimately
let's just dive in and take a look at a
brand new scene in hazel and how we can
set up lighting and shadows and i'll
demonstrate it working
on kind of a larger scale okay so this
was kind of the standard scene that i
think i showed last time
i have been playing with uh like the the
whole exposure
and all the kind of intensities around
quite a lot as well so you see that the
skylight has like
you know an intensity that you can set
um which can be useful because some of
these are just
really really bright like you can see
this one is hugely bright as well
um but this is kind of a base scene so
the way that i started testing these
shadows
uh in like in the context of a larger
world is i added a mesh
that was essentially just like a large
plane so if i go back to these meshes
and select i think it's in
models actually and i just create a
large plane like this
moving it downwards a little bit you
should obviously see a shadow on it i
think at that point due to a bug i
didn't even see a shadow on the plane so
i had to
iron out some issues with that as well
but if we just make this a little bit
bigger in general it's quite a lot
bigger
um and maybe change the shadow fade
distance to be like 450 or something a
little bit higher
then uh you know what we should be able
to do basically is we should be able
to duplicate this and just move it all
around
right so i'll just duplicate it a few
times and obviously the idea is i'm just
pressing ctrl d
to duplicate it we should see shadows
everywhere right and i can duplicate
maybe this as well and move it somewhere
um
where is it just like that
uh it doesn't really matter too much i
mean you don't really need to do this
too much but the point is you should be
able to see those shadows and you can
see that we can see the shadows and
really no matter where we are in the
world
now they will fade out right because we
have a set of a maximum shadow distance
um like a yeah a maximum shadow distance
um
and you can see there are some issues
coming in with huge frustums like this
so
you can actually fix this by going into
uh the scene renderer and then tweaking
the shadows as i mentioned so maybe like
minus 150 150 is
a little bit uh a little bit of a better
kind of near-far plane
you can see that wherever we are right
if we come in close here we should be
able to see really nice looking shadows
really anywhere in the world um and so
this is like a good way to test it
because
at this point we're about i mean that's
not that far we're 200 meters
away from the origin of the world but
the point is it doesn't matter where we
are because the camera the the shadow
mapping moves with the camera obviously
you know if i zoom in somewhere else
then obviously we're going to see
uh you know high resolution shadows
wherever the camera is
so that in general is obviously a really
good way to just test this and see
in general how how shadows work in the
context of a larger world without
necessarily having like this huge world
to explore because unfortunately that's
one of the things that i haven't really
created yet in hazel
i should create some kind of like like a
racing track or some kind of
massive environment that we can actually
walk around in and speaking of which
environment that we can walk around in
we do have a little bit of a sponsor
scene that i will show as well so
sponsor of course is
is um quite a popular 3d model that
people use with scenes this is me
loading the sponsor scene
this is what it looks like um we can
come in here and this is quite a large
uh scene here i mean this actually
scaled down to a tenth of the size
but um it's a pity we can't really
measure it
but i think do we have the grid in the
middle no not really
um yeah it would be nice to measure it
i guess what i can do now is just maybe
add like a little cube
because our cube i believe is a one
meter cube
one by one by one meter so if i just add
a
one meter cube here so this is one meter
so actually it looks like sponsor's even
larger than it should be
um let me uh i can't even select it
where's my cube so you can see that um
oh i just scaled it up which defeats the
whole purpose but this is one meter
so this is clearly not to scale sponsors
a lot larger than it should be because i
think one meter is probably
you know more like that size or
something um
but anyway so uh so this is quite a
large scene is my point and you can see
obviously some of the cascades here and
this light's actually quite soft maybe
i'll make it a little bit harder here
but this is like a demonstration i guess
of shadows in a much
larger scene and i can come over here uh
to the directional light and
maybe like maneuver it and there we go
that looks kind of nice
and then we can play with the lighting
to make it look a little bit maybe more
like a night scene that might look nice
so if we come over here to the
directional light
in fact let's just reduce the skylight's
contribution so if we make it we can
make it look really dramatic if we just
uh basically cut out a lot of the
skylight i mean if we completely cut it
out then obviously we'll have
just completely black ambience here but
if i
um add like you know as we start to add
a little bit more of it it can
start to look a lot nicer and then in
fact with this directional light we can
also play with that intensity to light
it however we like
so i might i might give it quite a high
um higher intensity maybe like 1.5 here
and then let's set the color to be
something more like
maybe like a bluish kind of tint right
so now we're starting to look like
moonlight
um and it could even look like a bit of
a night scene
we can also play with our camera's
exposure a little bit if it's looking a
little bit too dark i did also spend
some time
optimizing these soft shadows so this is
still the soft shadow rendering you can
see we're about eight milliseconds per
frame
which isn't like amazing but it's also
not bad when you consider the fact that
obviously
this resolution here is is quite high
it's it's higher than full hd because my
monitor is quite is quad hd 2560 by
1440 and i think before my optimizations
this was something like
30 milliseconds and it basically wasn't
even hitting 60fps so with some
optimization this has gotten a lot
better there's still
quite a lot i could do but i think for
now this is probably
enough if you guys are interested in
seeing some of those optimizations and
also let me know and i can
maybe make a video about some of those
but yeah that's basically our sponsor
scene looks pretty good
i'm still working on some other effects
that'll make this look even nicer such
as bloom
and depth of field as well which isn't
which i'm not
quite ready to show off just yet also i
think there's like
some issues here with alpha rendering
but overall i'm pretty happy
with this and with some 3d physics it's
going to be really nice to see the scene
as like a place that you can basically
walk in and interact with
in play mode so that's something that
i'm definitely looking forward to doing
pretty soon as well and we've also got
this scene which is
basically like a little game that i made
i think i've shown this before but it's
a little bit of a game demonstrating
some 2d physics and some scripting
behaviors because like we have this
player entity that's all like fully
scripted and everything and so this is a
good uh example
also showing how the shadows depend on
where the camera is in the world and how
they kind of move with the camera
because if we hit play here
and we start playing this scene
obviously wherever we are this shadow
will kind of remain here
so if i just move across the world you
can see that wherever we are it doesn't
matter because the shadow map always
follows the camera
and here we are and in fact if we tweak
some of these parameters a little bit
um so if we go to directional light and
sometimes it's nice to use this gizmo
sometimes it's it's not sometimes i
prefer using
the controls over here but we can kind
of cover a little bit more with this
light here maybe make it look more like
this
and then with the skylight dip it i mean
this is like you could spend hours here
honestly
but the point is that you can see where
we're kind of in shadow here and
as we move uh across the world
everything should more or less look
correct
so there you go that looks a little bit
weird but i think it's because we're
partially being
um obstructed by that and of course you
can tweak this stuff
in real time uh it won't save when you
when you stop playing the scene but you
can always tweak the stuff in real time
in case you're working on
getting something looking good and it's
really nice to see
a dynamic scene like this you know with
a whole bunch
of uh shadows as well so if i duplicate
this a few times so that we have
a little bit more physics going on in
the world and i hit play you can see how
these things
fall around and and everything obviously
moves with them in terms of the shadows
so that looks pretty cool i think as
well so yeah anyway i hope you guys
enjoyed this video a bit of a deeper
look
into shadows and hazel in the context of
scenes if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button i've got a few more
devlogs planned for
shadows maybe digging into some of the
deeper aspects as well as
just lighting a scene from scratch this
stuff is going to be a lot
nicer i think once we can hook it up
with 3d physics as i mentioned so that
we can actually interact with this world
and maybe
script some certain things happening but
overall i really enjoyed working on this
stuff and it's really satisfying when it
all comes together and when you can
actually
you know make a nice scene out of it and
you know have it look
nice there's just something about about
graphics and rendering that's just super
satisfying and
as i men as i've mentioned before i
absolutely love it if you guys want to
check this out for yourselves you can
help support hazel by going to
patreon.com
the channel and you will get access to
all of this source code as well as like
the backlog of live streams and an
amazing community where we
talk about this kind of stuff and share
knowledge around so thank you so much to
everyone who does help
support this would not be here without
you guys
and from the bottom of my heart thank
you it's really cool for me to see how
much we've achieved
with hazel and just the the journey over
the last couple of years has been
amazing i've learned so much honestly by
working on all this kind of stuff and
it's amazing that we're kind of getting
to the point where
where people can actually start creating
content with this so huge thank you as
always like
could not be more thankful and more
grateful let me know what you guys
thought of this devlog and what you want
to see
in the future and i will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]
you